let's go to our caller from the 4:06
area code who's calling from 406 today
that's me yes it is who's this oh hi
David well I am calling from Jamaica my
first American Colin you are indeed the
first Jamaican caller we've ever had
I feel so grateful for this particularly
I gave unto this living thing because
initially because of pile and then I was
drawn into your community because I
think was an extent you have a little
bit more realistic approach to
progresses progresses even then I like
highly no and I liked or we particularly
but I think your approach is more
realistic thank my question to you do my
questions even though it is sometimes I
wonder if you're too consumed by your
critique of Trump so sometimes you might
miss why keep is embodied in its own
right because I like to do what I'm
trying to say that I have a problem like
that Trump has like many people doing
home but I will fix it and sometime I
don't think your critique properly
address some of those issues I totally
understand what you're saying yeah I
mean listen it's not I'm not even
suffering from the delusion that Biden
would fix all of the problems of Trump
the analogy I've been using is we just
need to get the ball back so we have the
opportunity of putting some points on
the board and we're not going to put all
of the points on the board with Joe
Biden but it's it's the opportunity now
what's going on in the back are you in a
restaurant it sounds extremely loud
there no ma'am but my mother is feeling
quiet oh is that right it's not like hot
pots and pans yeah no listen I mean
you're you're bringing I I agree with
you I
take no qualms with you if I have given
anyone the impression that Joe Biden
fixes all of the problems that are
evident with Trump that's not the case
but some problems would be fixed and we
would stop doing as much damage and and
it's a harm reduction approach I make no
qualms about that okay I do wanna say
however there is what do I say come work
economic concerns especially in this
time given that like for example done
with the bellows that happen right after
the current of verse yeah people are
pointing to if it was a job and the same
thing would have like they're both
identical an economical skill but enough
cultural skill they are different and
some people are pointing that's not you
know so here's where I take a little bit
of issue with what you're pointing out
if the argument is Biden would also have
done bailouts yes Biden would also have
done bailouts here's what I think the
differences would have been if if Trump
had been Biden instead he would have
listened more to the medical science
community from the beginning and the
pandemic would never have been as bad
and thus it would have necessitated it
would not have necessitated the same
economic reaction and my belief is that
it would have been done in a less crony
istic way under Joe Biden than Donald
Trump so yes they both would have done
bailouts but I think we would be far
better off in total economically if it
had been Joe Biden at the helm
rather than Donald Trump I want this
wish because I know you have a little
college and upon what what I wanted to
another question I wanted us is
regarding this free speech stuff and my
critique of the left is that the left is
giving the right ammonition to to
believe that they are though what the
so-called fighters are free speech
and that's to an extent drive me crazy
because I think some people are the
right teeth these are the opportunity to
say when they were early cameras free
speech but Wendy life is so like the
kinds of culture the walk ISM it kind of
give them a monition to feel that be I
completely agree with you
the the entire idea or meme of the left
is against open discussion and the right
is for it the left wants to cancel
everything and the right wants to hear
every I think it's I think it's you're
completely correct in your analysis and
we've got to take the narrative back my
friend I'm gonna let you go it sounds
like things it sounds like the main
course is about to be served
yeah sure thank you first call from
Jamaica we absolutely love it and on
that note let's go out on a high we are
going to go to a break I apologize I was
not able to get to everybody today but
we did hear from some great great people
and I will take calls again